- If you know BuzzFeed, you know we're obsessed
with finding the next big Internet challenge.
^- What are you?
- This time, we don't just wanna master it.
We wanna make it go viral.
When I found out about the #LemonFaceChallenge,
I was like, "Oh, yeah, I can do this.
"I can eat a lemon.
"Lemons are delicious."
But then I found out that the Lemon Face Challenge
is actually for a good cause.
Aubreigh, who has DIPG, and her mother
were hoping that people will take the challenge
and donate to the cause.
The Lemon Face Challenge is already catching on.
The Arizona Diamondbacks have done it, the LA Dodgers.
You're eating a lemon, making a silly, sour face.
You might look at somebody biting into a lemon
and think, "Wait, how in the world
"does that help kids with DIPG?"
Well, that's exactly what I'm going to ask Brooke,
who, along with her daughter,
started the Lemon Face Challenge.
- We had always heard of the Ice Bucket Challenge
for ALS and wanted to do something
to get awareness out there.
They thought of when life gives you lemons,
you make lemonade.
- Oh, that makes so much sense!
When you're given lemons, make lemonade.
So, like, the lemonade that you're making
is basically raising awareness,
and encouraging people to donate to charity.
- [Brooke] So the ALS bucket challenge was a huge success.
It raised something like 115 million in 2014 alone.
And that money led to research breakthroughs.
It was incredible.
- Do you know anything about research going on?
- We know that it only affects about 300 a year.
There are a few trials or something going on.
It just doesn't seem to be a big target.
- If you can get the awareness out there,
they may be more apt to try to find more trials to do.
- If somebody does the Lemon Face Challenge
and they wanna donate money--
- [Brooke] Two ways.
- We wanna make sure that people realize
if you donate to Aubreigh's Army,
^that is for her medical expenses.
^We were looking into a foundation
that handles DIPG that's called The Cure Starts Now.
- [Sara] thecurestartsnow.org.
- Their thing is targeting research for DIPG.
- You can give money to help Aubreigh,
or you can give money to help future research.
I have a lemon here.
- We happen to have two.
- Are you guys ready?
- Ready to do it
- Let's do it.
Mm.
- Gets me every time.
- It's sour, but it still tastes good to me.
I still like it.
- So we end that with when life hands you lemons,
you make lemonade.
- Is there any, like, celebrity
you wanna challenge to do it?
- [Brooke] Ellen.
- You hear that, Ellen?
You have officially been Lemon Challenged.
I accept the Lemon Face Challenge
to raise awareness for DIPG.
I challenge you, Eric.
I know you're out there in LA,
but you're gonna eat this lemon,
and you're gonna donate for DIPG.
- So Sara just tweeted me the Lemon Face Challenge.
I really wanna do this.
One, because I love lemons.
And two, because it's a really important
and great cause, and we can
use BuzzFeed to make it go viral.
LA sucks!
I have to walk 30 minutes one way to get some lemons.
I'm sweating so hard right now.
- All right, Eric, get the lemons.
I challenged Eric.
Check one.
I'm gonna get more people to do
the Lemon Face Challenge than Eric.
All right, this is now a challenge.
It's a competition.
And it is for a good cause.
Let's do it.
- My name is Clark, and I'm about to
do the Lemon Face Challenge for DIPG.
(upbeat music)
- So it looked a little iffy for Eric there
on whether he would be able to even get himself
to do the Lemon Challenge, but Eric pulled through.
So I got my lemon.
I think you just eat it and make a face.
I'm a sensitive Jewish boy.
I could feel the heartburn starting.
But I did it for you, Aubreigh!
I wanna make this go viral,
and I am currently in the LA office,
where most of our big BuzzFeed personalities are.
So I'm gonna go around the office
and get all them to eat some lemons for Aubreigh.
Let's go.
- Ha ha ha.
- [Eric] All right, Curly, I need you to eat some lemons
for the Lemon Face Challenge.
- Lemons are my favorite.
Aubreigh, I hope you're doing well.
Sending you tons of love and all good wishes
and all the warmth that you deserve.
Mm.
- Ladylike is over there.
I'm gonna go get someone from Ladylike.
- Well, this was a pretty simple challenge.
Pretty tasty, too.
- Oh, that's something.
- [Woman] Oh, my god!
- Ew.
- Everyone has lemons.
Lemons are easy to get, unless you're Eric in LA.
So Eric got a ton of people,
and I got a ton of people.
I mean, honestly, we both won.
^So grab a lemon, do the Lemon Face Challenge,
^post it on social media, and let's get this trending.
That's why we're donating the entire budget
for this video to Aubreigh's Army.
If you can take the time to do something
as fun and goofy as bite a lemon
and give some money to these charities,
you should do it.